problema número 120 david tiene de
libros que son tres veces más que los
que tiene juan y la mitad de los que
tiene pablo cuántos libros tienen entre
los tres en términos de vamos a anotar
los datos david d tiene tres veces más
libros que juan y también nos dicen que
david tiene la mitad de libros que los
que tiene pablo lo que quieren saber es
esto los hijos que tiene david más los
que tienen juan más los que tiene pablo
que es jota en términos de bueno de esta
vamos a despejar jota dividimos 93 nos
queda que jota
los libros que tienen juan es igual a
los que tiene david entre 3 y todo lo
dejamos en términos de d es lo que
estamos buscando hacemos lo mismo aquí
vamos a despejar la p y esto lo hacemos
multiplicando ambos lados por 2 2 por d
es igual a p los libros que tiene pablo
y ahora está jota y está p las vamos a
sustituir acá nos va
de más jota que es de entre tres de
entre tres más peques dos de dos de
ahora vamos a sumar todo esto tenemos
que encontrar el común denominador para
poder sumar todo esto como fracción
vamos a poner el común denominador como
33 esto entre 3 es lo mismo que 3 de
entre 3 le estamos dejando igual así que
aquí es 3 d
más de entre 3 pues estaba tal cual la
pasamos aquí la de ahora 2 d para
dejarlo en términos de tercios tenemos
que multiplicar y dividir por 32 por 36
de entre 3 + 6 d
y esto es igual a 34 610 de entre 3 que
es nuestra opción c siguiente problema
problema número 121 hay 8 equipos en una
liga cada equipo juega con los otros
equipos exactamente una vez cada juego
se realiza con dos equipos cuál es el
número total de juegos realizados vemos
esto como una matriz para comprenderlo
mejor tenemos ocho equipos vamos a
ponerlos aquí uno dos tres cuatro cinco
seis siete ocho que van a jugar entre
ellos entonces aquí también ponemos
arriba uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis
siete y ocho esto vamos a verlo como una
matriz como un cuadrado vamos a hacer
esto algo así para hacerlo rápido y cada
uno de estos va a tener una división
de dibujar lo más rápido que se pueda
para no llevarnos demasiado en el
problema
y aquí lo que nos dicen es que los
equipos no pueden jugar entre ellos o
sea un equipo no puede jugar contra sí
mismo entonces está que está aquí en la
diagonal estos no se van a tomar en
cuenta pues es un equipo consigo mismo
esto no lo vamos a tomar en cuenta
nos quedan estos otros espacios sin
embargo nos están diciendo que cada
equipo juega con otro equipo exactamente
una vez no es que este equipo 2 juegue
contra el equipo 1 y el equipo 1 juegue
con el equipo 2 así que esta parte de
aquí todo esto nada más vamos a ocupar
una mitad de las celdas que nos quedan
es decir que los partidos que se van a
realizar equipo 1 contra equipo 2 equipo
uno contra equipo 3 contra el 4 con 35
etcétera luego el equipo 2 va a jugar
contra el equipo 3 ya que el 2 ya jugó
con el 1 no se vuelve a repetir esa
combinación y juega con todos estos y
así vamos a tener toda esta parte que es
la que va a tener los juegos realizados
ahora para saber la cantidad de juegos
que se llevan a cabo qué es lo que
necesitamos saber primero
a ver todos los espacios que tiene esta
matriz ésta es una matriz de 8 x 8 lo
multiplicamos 8 por 8 nos va a dar 64 a
ese 64 que es el total de los cuadritos
le quitamos estos de la diagonal que
pues son 1 en cada renglón así que serán
8 cuadritos que quitamos 64 -8 es igual
a 56 y quedamos que sólo nos van a
interesar como cada equipo juega solo
una vez con todos los demás vamos a
tener de los cuadritos que nos quedan
solo vamos a usar oa contar la mitad de
ellos 56 entre 2 es igual a 28
estos cuadritos son 28 por lo que vamos
a tener solamente 28 partidos en nuestra
temporada que es la opción c el
siguiente problema
problema número 122 la operación theta
se define como a etb iguala a menos b
entre a más b para todo número ave que
cumplan con que sea diferente de b y
esto es para evitar que tengamos aquí un
0 y esta edición sea indefinida si a es
diferente de c y tenemos a teta se
iguala 0 cuál es el valor de s vamos a
desarrollar esta operación atentase es
igual a menos c entre a más y tenemos
que hacer diferente de c por lo que aquí
no vamos a tener un cero y vamos a poder
realizar esta división y nos están
diciendo que esto es igual a cero
si el denominador no es cero y el
resultado de esta fracción es cero
entonces el numerador tiene que ser
igual a cero éste no es 0 10 este para
que la reacción sea 0 eso tiene que ser
igual hacer a menos se debe ser igual a
0 para conocer el valor de c sumamos c
en ambos lados nos va
es igual a ce y esta es nuestra opción
el siguiente problema número 123 el
precio de una de comida para 15 personas
es de 207 dólares que incluye una
propiedad del 15% cuál es el precio de
comida por personas sin incluir la
propina nos están preguntando el precio
de 15 personas sin propina este el
precio de la comida de 15 personas sin
la propina va a ser igual al
multiplicarse por 1.15 que es el
porcentaje de la propina nos debe dar
igual a 207 que es el precio con la
propina si queremos conocer este solito
tenemos que dividir todo entre 1.5 el
precio de la comida de 15 personas sin
la propina es igual a 207 entre 1.15
pero lo que quieren es el precio
promedio por persona así que todo esto
hay que dividirlo entre 15
para encontrar el precio individual es
entre 15 y todo esto entre 15 esto así
como se ve parece un cálculo algo
engorroso pero veamos si podemos
simplificar esto es igual a 207 entre
1.15 por esto es lo mismo que
multiplicarlo por su recíproco que es 1
entre 15 que es igual a 207 entre 15 por
1.3 vamos a ver qué pasa si yo divido
207 entre 1.15 vamos a hacerlo aquí
abajo y con otro color para que se vea
que es un cálculo aparte 207 entre 1.15
o que hay aquí tengo que deshacerme de
este punto decimal así que aquí agregó
dos ceros y recorro el punto dos lugares
de manera que pueda recorrer estos dos
lugares también y tener 115 que divide a
20.700 vamos a ver aquí vamos a
multiplicar por 1 115 207 ciento
nos va a dar 92 bajamos un 0 aquí vamos
a ver si lo multiplicamos que se acerca
a este 9 pues vamos a multiplicarlo por
8 8 por 5 48 por 18 412 llevamos 18 por
18 más 19 tenemos aquí una edición
exacta ahora este 0 pues bueno pasa xxi
tal cual lo subimos y esta división nos
va a dar 180 entonces esto es igual a
180 dólares esta división ahora nos
falta multiplicarlo por 1 entre 15 o
dividirlo entre 15 este 180 vamos a
hacer la división 180 entre 15 115 18 -
15 30 230 menos 30 es igual a cero esta
es una división exacta por lo que nos va
a costar 12 dólares por persona por
persona la comida sin la propina y con
esto terminamos los problemas de este
vídeo nos vemos en el siguiente